là haut dit ok ça c'est en quelque sorte
c'est un processus par lequel le client
au moment de passer à la caisse
il demande à l'hôtesse de caisse
d'arrondir le montant de ses achats
voilà si vous faites par exemple 48
euros d'achat vous pouvez à ce moment-là
demandé à la caissière de vous prendre
sur 50 euros et les deux euros de
différence
vos directement sur les comptes de la
croix rouge cette action justement de
dont google à pois rouges et dans quel
but
quelles sont les cibles justement de ces
deux saisons et bien aujourd'hui on à
aimants énormément de besoins et vous
savez pendant la période de confinement
on a fait beaucoup des opérations de
portage de colis alimentaires un petit
peu partout effectivement sur le plan de
la trésorerie ça nous a beaucoup coûté
et donc en fait nous avons besoin de
reconstituer la trésorerie et par
ailleurs nous avons beaucoup d'action en
cours dans le domaine social du
secourisme de la jeunesse et nous avons
besoin effectivement de certains nombres
de dodo la générosité publique de façon
à pouvoir maintenir va amplifier ses
actions que nous faisons auprès de la
population population qui a souvent très
démunis est très fragilisée par les
événements sanitaires notamment